JOINING US IS JOHN SUMMERS, A
FORMER COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
FOR HARRY REID.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS
STORY THAT AN ALLY OF CHRISTINE
FORD, ACCORDING TO LELAND KEYSER
FORD, ACCORDING TO LELAND KEYSERTRIED TO GET KEYSER TRIED TO GET
TRIED TO GET KEYSER TRIED TO GET
HER TO CHANGE HER SWORN
TOMORROW, WHICH IS A CRIME.
IT’S WRONG.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WELL, I DON’T KNOW THAT I
AGREE IT’S A CRIME AND IT’S
SOMETHING THAT WE’VE SEEN ON
BOTH SIDES.
WE KNOW THAT KAVANAUGH WAS OFF
TALKING TO HIS FRIENDS, SHE WAS
OFF TALKING TO HERS.
WHAT IT BOILS DOWN --
>> Tucker: I MEAN, I THINK I
FOLLOWED IT CLOSELY.
IS THERE AN ALLEGATION THAT
SOMEONE WAS PUSHED TO CHANGE
SWORN TESTIMONY?
>> THERE WAS TALK ABOUT
KAVANAUGH TALKING WITH HIS
FRIENDS THAT MIGHT BE APPROACHED
BY THE FBI.
THE WAY --
>> Tucker: BUT THEY --
>> THE SWORN TESTIMONY WAS NOT
THE WAY IT WAS WRITTEN IN THE
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" --
>> Tucker: SHE SAID SHE WAS
PUSHED TO CHANGE --
>> SHE SAID SHE WAS ASKED TO
RE-VISIT HER ACCOUNT.
I’M NOT DOING TO DEFEND THAT.
IT’S NOT FOR ME.
I DON’T KNOW IF IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING NOR DO.
BOTH SIDES ARE GUILTY.
THE RIGHT THING TO DO IS FOR
EVERY ONE TO TAKE A BREATH.
TAKE A STEP BACK.
ACTUALLY TAKE THE TIME TO GO IN
AND INVESTIGATE ALL THE STUFF.
BOTH ON BEHALF OF THE ACCUSED
AND THE ACCUSER.
SO THERE COULD BE SOME CLARITY
BROUGHT TO THIS.
THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT’S WHAT IS MISSING IN THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE THERE WAS A RUSH
TO GET IT DONE.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE --
>> YEAH, ONLY SEVEN FBI
INVESTIGATIONS INTO KAVANAUGH.
I THINK WE WOULD NEED AN EIGHTH
FBI, TOO, TO CLEAR HIS NAME FROM
CHARGES THAT DON’T MAKE ANY
SENSE.
>> AND HASTERT HAD CLEARANCE AND
HE WAS A CHILD MOLESTER --
>> Tucker: WHAT WE’RE NOT GOING
TO DO IS IMPUGN BRETT
KAVANAUGH’S REPUTATION BY
COMPARING HIM TO A CHILD
MOLESTER.
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
YOUR SENATOR FROM WEST VIRGINIA,
JOE MANCHIN, ANNOUNCED HIS VOTE,
WHICH IS WHAT HIS VOTERS WANT
AND ANGRY LEFT WING CHILDREN
SURROUND HIM AND SCREAM AT HIM.
DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
IS THAT THE KIND OF DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS THAT YOU WANT?
>> PEOPLE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPROACH THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS --
>> Tucker: JOE MANCHIN --
>> NOT SCREAM.
I AGREE.
>> Tucker: I DEFEND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT THE WAY THE LEFT DOES
NOT.
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO DO IT, I
GUESS, BUT IS THAT WHAT YOU
WANT?
DO YOU WANT PEOPLE SCREAMING AT
LAWMAKERS UNTIL THEY CHANGE
THEIR VIEW?
IF THAT’S OKAY, WHY IS IT NOT
OKAY TO SLASH THEIR TIRES?
THROW MOLOTOV COCKTAILS?
IF YOU’RE GOING TO BULLY PEOPLE,
WHAT IS THE KIND OF LIMIT TO
THAT?
>> YOU HAVE BULLYING ON BOTH
SIDES.
WE KNOW --
>> Tucker: NO, YOU DON’T.
>> YOU ABSOLUTELY DO, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SHOW ME THE MOBS OF
SCREAMING RIGHT WING CHILDREN --
>> IT’S A WASTE OF TIME TO
SCREAM AT MANCHIN.
HE VOTED THE WAY I EXPECTED ALL
THE TIME.
WHICH IS VIEWED BY HIM AS THE
POLITICALLY SAFE WAY TO GO.
I’M REALLY IMPRESSED WITH
SENATOR COLLINS, HOWKOWSKI AND
HEITKAMP.
IT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT ALL THREE
OF THEM PUT SOME SERIOUS THOUGHT
INTO THIS.
I STILL EXPECTED COLLINS TO VOTE
THE WAY THAT WE EXPECT HER TO
VOTE TOMORROW ON THE
CONFIRMATION, BUT IT WAS CLEAR
THAT SHE PUT SOME THOUGHT INTO
IT.
I DON’T AGREE WITH WHAT SHE SAID
BUT IT’S CLEAR SHE PUT THOUGHT
INTO IT.
>> Tucker: SHE MADE A REASONABLE
CASE AND NOW SHE’S BEING
DISMISSED BY SOME RIGHT WING
CRAZY --
>> THE SAME THOUGHTFULNESS CAN
BE APPLIED TO LISA MURKOWSKI AND
HEITKAMP.